[Music]
Chuck I got another explainer for you
all right this has to do with making
toast
okay
I'm just saying you know sometimes when
you bring these up man I feel like you
just like you're punking me you know
like I'm like I'm just like let me just
see if I what I can get something to go
along with the astrophysics of making
toast because you know it's like Neil
deGrasse Tyson right world renowned
scientists and science Communicator I'd
love to talk to you about something
scientifically relevant oh yeah please
do tell let's talk toast what
all right so toast here's the deal okay
all right and I don't know if you ever
paid attention to what's going on inside
a toaster okay all right but it's it's
fascinating I have smoked a lot of weed
I have been high out of my mind I have
never looked at the toaster event I
wonder what's going on in there all
right here's the thing okay here's the
thing uh toast if you're gonna toast
fresh bread okay okay it will spend most
of its time in the toaster
most of the time
not Browning
okay and is this fresh white bread
because that would make sense
[Laughter]
yes it's easier to see the Browning on
White Bread so this is a white bread
example okay can you blame it because
let's be honest in bread Society
but the Seven Grain Blended model is
coming along okay so here's the thing
and let me tell you something
Pumpernickel there goes to property
values in the bread box
I forgot all about Pumpernickel that's
some dark ass bread right there right
now
okay go ahead
I'm about to get us in trouble I'm gonna
stop all right so if you if you observe
the bread most of the time ninety
percent of the time I didn't do no
exactly but it's very high percent of
the time it's in the toaster it doesn't
change color at all oh my God okay
because it can't change color
as long as it's moist
okay because the highest temperature you
can heat the bread is 212 degrees and
that's not hot enough to toast the bread
I gotcha I mean that really does make
sense think about this right it's like
trying to start a fire with green uh
kindly you can't you can't in fact if
you put a green log on an already
established fire the log is not going to
ignite you know what's going to happen
it's going to hiss out all the moisture
for the next hour yeah all right because
the log can't get hotter than the
highest temperature that water can get
and the water that's in the log tops out
at 212 degrees you're gonna have a 212
degree log until there's no water left
that's cool and then it'll ignite that's
right oh wow okay so your toast in the
toaster if you keep looking at it it is
going to be your white toast it's gonna
be white and white and white and what
the heat is doing is like get out of
there you water molecules get out get
out and it's only doing it to the top
Edge not to the middle because the heat
is only hitting the top the outer edges
right so so the heat is like uh uh the
lactose matters movement yeah
Chuck you talk you need race counseling
okay I think you
all right so so go ahead all right so
once all of the moisture
on that outer edge of the bread has
evaporated right it can now toast the
bread
the bread molecules the proteins and the
and the carbohydrates revealing the
carbon the carbon is black okay if you
leave the bread in too long it's
completely black all right but you have
all these golden tip that all happens in
like the last minute that your toast is
in there because it took all the rest of
that time to heat up the water and
evaporate it that is pretty doggo and
cool to be honest and
I I got a little excited when you said
that because I've never considered it
however
I don't have a toaster I have a um a
toaster oven okay so okay so in in the
oven any oven if you're gonna use a
broiler right the same thing you layer
the bread and you check and you check in
it and you keep checking it you say it's
not making progress let me go away for
five minutes no because the moment the
moisture is gone that sucker Brown's in
instance absolutely okay so it's not a
linear it's not a linear phenomenon
that's what I'm trying to say like if it
were a graph it would bump along the
bottom correct and then all of a sudden
it shoots straight up almost yeah almost
straight up almost straight up so uh and
I know this because uh just the other
day when you it's so weird now I can't
believe that I'm recalling this
I said what's taking this toast so damn
okay
and then I turned I went into the
refrigerator I pulled out some butter
and uh um fig spread and I went back and
the toast was brown
there it is so that is so wild you lived
this experience this experience it's
it's also why you can
um boil water in a paper cup
okay okay and I've done this experiment
many times so so wait you yeah I mean
yeah you just dropped the paper cup
inside the pot of boiling water okay no
no no that's that's not what it no so
you can you can take a paper cup and you
have to be careful about this because
some paper cups have rims on the bottom
that are not actively touching the water
on the inside that will burn okay but if
you have a wide enough bottom and you
have like a Bunsen burner remember these
you put the flame on the paper cup in
the bottom if the paper cup has water in
it what is the hottest temperature the
paper can get the temperature of the
water water okay and so it'll sit there
and boil the water and it'll keep
boiling the water until all the water
evaporates then your paper cup Burns
this is why it's so hard to burn someone
at the stake you think oh let me just
ignite you this is very medieval here
let's put you on the stake and just
ignite you you can't just ignite okay
yeah well there's liquid in you right
the real the real reason why this is
very difficult to do is because we have
laws against that that's why okay
that's the actual reason it's difficult
thank you let me get out of my medieval
so what they would do especially the
Catholic Church to make sure you would
burn that sometimes they would burn you
upside down and that way
um will control the blood or the blood
would drain and as the blood drains then
you have no liquid left in you and you
burn faster or you can burn in other
directions where you retain the blood
because if you don't want the blood come
out there's some other religious ritual
where the whole person has to be burned
including their blood but then the blood
has to
still evaporate you'll die before that
happens of course but in terms of
igniting the body it just doesn't simply
happen that way and this is sped up if
you have fast moving air hot air across
the the food yes this this is like a
wind heat Factor the Opera we have a we
have a a an explainer on wind chill
factor and wind heat factors yes okay
because if it's cold and the wind is
blowing you feel colder cold Earth if
it's hot and the air that's blowing is
hotter than your skin temperature you'll
feel hotter all right okay so if you put
food in let's say an air fryer yes what
does that mean okay so they are going to
brown your food
fast because they're moving hot air
across and they're evaporating any
possible moisture on that surface and
the faster the wind goes the faster
you'll evaporate it the faster you can
get to the Browning can't live without
an air fryer I'm sorry it's amazing
they're wonderful
yeah they're really air toasters because
uh you know unless the the surface is
sprinkled with oil and then the oil will
fry the you know you can heat the oil so
you're you're still
oil frying but you're using air to heat
the oil to fry the food right but if it
didn't have any oil it's just a fast
toaster exactly
you mean I spent 400 on a toaster yes
you did yes
yes you did indeed
that's everything you wanted to know
about toast and why it's not a linear
process well that was fun
do this experiment okay take a slice of
bread and let leave it out until it just
gets hard a little crusty just leave out
okay we'll get across it'll just get get
hard it's no longer squishy and then you
have another one that squishy that you
just took out of the bag okay they're
both at the same temperature
right okay now put them both in the in
your in your toaster oven we're both in
the toaster and the one that had the the
Lost moisture will toast ten times
faster quicker okay oh yeah oh there you
go
so yeah and it's already on its way to
being toast it's not that's right you
leave it out well why do you keep
leaving the bread out
pre-toasting pre-toast yeah sweet toast
and one other thing a reminder of how
surface deep the color is okay because
it's only what that sort of radiant
energy can touch and anything's behind
anything else it's not C in your toaster
thing all right so a reminder that is if
you happen to burn the toast right you
just take a bread knife or a knife not
you know a knife and scrape off the
black right and then there's like this
and you can you can salvage many a burnt
toast that way or you could just accept
the fact that it is black and enjoy it
for this beautiful Blackness you could
do that as well okay
yeah Chuck totally definitely needs race
therapy we're going to work on it
you care to know about making toast but
I put that the thermodynamics of
toasting
that is awesome we gotta title this just
that the thermodynamics of toasting okay
yeah and so and and the takeaway here is
however long you're staring at the
Unbound toast let that not be the
measure of how much longer you have to
wait yes
I know this firsthand absolutely yeah
yeah you got it all right that's all we
got time for Chuck oh that was great
that was great that was great all right
not until next time I am Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
Toastmaster
for this episode only Toastmaster Chuck
and Neil I'm telling you to keep looking
up
thank you